lead track and field analysts in Rio for
NBC and he joins us now on the Dan
Patrick show Auto good morning is there
any chance he doesn't win tonight no I
don't think there is any chance that
Bolton's win but I think it could be a
lot closer than people expect because of
the Canadian de Graaff they were
laughing last night were you lad before
those who didn't see it the grass and
bolt bolts got the lead the grass is
coming on strong there at the end in the
semi-final and bolt looks back at him
kind of kind of say like dude woody what
are you doing he said afterwards Auto
that the grass was supposed to pull up
at the end or something like that I
think it had a pre-race conversation
where both came and said look young kid
I know you're gonna come out here and
try to challenge me at the semi final I
don't want to run that fast a ball and
out to the final and I think the grass
said oh yeah sure you saying yeah uh you
know let's just take it easy and then of
course he had a little surge at the end
so we had a lot of fun with that and I
thought the crowd there's there's no
sense of disrespect is there when
somebody is jogging and or laughing at
the end when when Auto you know that all
these other guys are taking this I mean
so seriously they've trained their
entire live life for this and then
here's this guy up in front having a
laugh I think it's a very fine line and
if you turn around and point or sort of
do it at the expense of somebody else I
think that would be frowned upon and
actually could be gone for
disqualification between it's depending
on the level that your Apple when you
have two guys I mean I used to do this
with Frankie threads back in the day
from Namibia but when you have two guys
who are really just engaging with each
other I think it's okay and I don't
really get the sense that anybody would
have been offended by those two sort of
carrying on upfront Otto should Usain
Bolt be a bigger star in the US should
should he have a stage aside from the
Olympics
because I feel like he is such a all
agree he's an amazing athlete but he is
so otherworldly he is so special that it
kind of it kind of is frustrating that
we as Americans don't embrace him more
for things and events other than the
Olympics I think it's something that
actually his his management should have
figured out a long time ago
you're not gonna be a megastar in the
United States unless you're on
television constantly and I think part
of the problem with you scene and his
popularity in the state I mean I I mean
I obviously am on the circuit and
following these guys all over the world
and be like this guy is a rock star
everywhere else in the world I think
part of the problem is that you don't
see stayin on television enough and we
spend and when he is on US television
he's fantastic he did a little piece on
The Ellen Show and that went over well
he's done SNL that went over well but
not on television enough he's not
performing on television enough that's
also because of track and field of now
the popularity of say the NFL or another
big United States sport but yeah he
should be a lot more popular but I think
it's because the American public does
not see him often enough Otto Bolden
from NBC joining us from Rio if it were
six months ago what do we think six
months ago so there's no big pre-olympic
hype yet do you think if he walks down
the street and say San Francisco he gets
noticed no no I've been around him in
the States and I've been around him in
just about every other continent and
when he is outside of the US you know
like I said Rockstar entourage and you
know people following him and everybody
wants to do the Usain Bolt lightning
pose with him he is just how did
everywhere else I thought that people
wouldn't recognize him in the state I
just think that it wouldn't be quite the
reception that he gets you know
everywhere else on the planet out of the
Danites dan dan Patrick screw here they
they were debating during the break how
fast they or the average guy will call
them average guys could run the 100
forget about the 200 run the 100 how
fast you think the
American male in his 30s in reasonably
average shape could run the 100 I think
they would be in the mid 12 second range
that Madison would not get 12 5 to 13
flats which means that they would not
get out of the first round here at the
Olympics on the women's I get out of the
first ride they couldn't find their way
to the track I think I think you're
being generous I don't think like an
average 32 year old guy that might be a
weekend warrior playing basketball
waiting for his Achilles to inevitably
blow out will will run the 100 in 12
seconds I just don't see it a lot of the
population gonna be in between 12 and 13
what what event Auto Bolden would you
like to see the average American take a
crack ad because running we've all run
at one point in our life but most of us
haven't say you know done the vault in
gymnastics you know or something
ridiculous like that this is a great
late night bit take the average American
and try to have him do the hardest
Olympic event what event would you like
to see them do Wow
the hardest Olympic event that I'd want
to see us civilians do just a laugh I
hmm
how about skeet shooting those guys
where trigger that's like when they go
Bam Bam and then they throw their gun
over the shoulder and open I mean though
those guys are nuts
what gets me about that skeet shooting
will people look at it and think oh yeah
I can do that it would be a lot of clay
pigeons flying all over the place
completely unharmed no way what what
freaks me out about that is when you're
watching that in Rio there's like
housing developments like half a mile
down the road like one of these guys
missed
I mean anyway Otto it's gonna be great
tonight thanks for getting up and
joining us this morning Usain Bolt Gale
goes for the sweep tonight goes for the
200-meter gold yet again Otto Bolden
from NBC thank you sir any time thank
you the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience